[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and in
years past we've had all kinds of 4k
displays right 4k tvs 4k monitors 4k
laptops and even a 4k smartphone and
then we also got tons of 4k cameras to
put video and content on those 4k
screens so 4k mirrorless cameras dslrs
and even the ones in our pockets are
shooting 4k
there's even 4k webcams now so you can
do skypes or facetimes and glorious high
definition if you wanted to that
option's there so it kind of seems like
pretty much everyone's making some sort
of consumer 4k camera
except canon
so in last year's state of 4k video we
came to the conclusion that pretty much
everything is better in 4k and that's
still true but now that it's 2017 it's
kind of time to take a look at the
bleeding edge getting pushed a little
further out and we can see what's uh
beyond 4k so first of all what is a k i
know most of you know but for the sake
of simplicity it represents about a
thousand horizontal pixels so 1920 by
1080 is about 2 000 pixels wide so we
can call it 2k
4k is 3840 by 2160 so again about 4 000
pixels wide so we call it 4k so okay you
may have seen my recent video about the
lg 5k display this is a monitor with a
resolution more than 4000 pixels wide
it's a 5120 by 2880 panel so 5k which is
actually a tessellation of four times
2560 by 1440 and it works great a single
thunderbolt 3 cable can push that video
resolution you get a native 4k window
with room around it to spare it's an
awesome setup so 5k exists and that's
great beyond that we don't really have
that many 6k or 7k resolution monitors
that's just sort of a weird resolution
for 16x9 so that brings us right to 8k
so 8k is 4 times 4k so 7680 by 4320
there are some 8k screens out there in
the world wikipedia has a little list of
pretty much every single 8k display ever
announced and there's about a dozen of
them right now but we did see a couple
of these 8k tvs at ces again this year
and that's kind of the most frequent
place you'll see them you don't really
see them in people's houses you see them
at places like ces and trade shows and
demo areas but broadcast television
isn't really 8k it's barely ever even 4k
and i'm gonna say there's a grand total
of probably less than 100 8k videos on
all of youtube including this one so
what's the deal what are they even
showing on these 8k tvs on the demo
areas
well a lot of slideshows 8k is a huge
resolution not just for videos but even
for photos 8k is 33 megapixels so to
fill an 8k tv pixel for pixel you need a
33 megapixel photo so the easiest way to
just play demo material at the 8k tv
you're showing at ces is just to play a
slideshow of really high res photos and
if you're lucky maybe even a time lapse
of really high-res photos and that's the
biggest difference between high-tech and
the bleeding edge of tech for all those
high-tech 4k displays we do have a whole
bunch of high-tech 4k cameras to capture
video to be shown on them and that's
awesome but for all the bleeding edge 8k
tvs we have out there the couple that
exist there are almost no video cameras
out there ready to shoot 8k video red is
an example of a company that's been
pioneering high resolution image capture
for the past couple years they were
really early to 4k and at this point
they have two different video sensors
that shoot 8k in production right now
including the one that's in this camera
that we're shooting us on which is why
there's not just an hd option and a
1440p option and a 4k option but also if
you're in chrome anyway an 8k option on
this video i'm guessing you probably
can't watch this video in full 8k even
if you did have an 8k display and you
did have the internet connection to be
able to download all this you'd also
need a gpu to be able to handle playing
back that video which it probably
doesn't at this point so if you tried to
click that ak button i'm sorry about
your gpu but people can still choose to
shoot videos in 8k now for the same
reason that they chose to shoot 4k when
everyone only had 1080p for better
sharpness and better reframing ability
more data points for better
stabilization a lot of minor stuff like
that but again that's why it's all at
the very high end so here's what to keep
in mind basically all the stuff is still
bleeding edge most people don't have a
4k tv yet but i would argue that it's
gotten to the point where if you're
buying a 4k tv now it should be 4k it's
just that people usually just don't buy
tvs unless they need a new one and most
people's 1080p tvs are working just fine
this cycle for people upgrading their
tvs is much much slower than maybe a
smartphone for example where you get a
new contract every two years so
basically we're at this merging point in
2017 where if you go to like a best buy
or if you look on amazon or basically
any electronics store then 4k is
mainstream it's everywhere it's ready to
go but if you go through people's
apartments and people's living rooms and
look at their tvs you'll find that
that's a lot less common there's still
plenty of 1080p tvs
so that's where we're at and that is the
state of 4k
thanks for watching talk to you guys in
the next one
peace
you